welcome to Vienna to the ftth Council
Europe's investors stay more than 100
people have gathered together today to
discuss how to accelerate fiber
deployments in Europe and write you come
on in and join the discussions we see a
lot of differences in the way in which
fiber-to-the-home is developing we see a
lot of rollout coverage and also take up
in the Eastern European countries
particularly the smaller ones today in
Poland we've got demand for sure we've
got visualizations we will have clouds
so there is a demand and people are
looking for the good quality broadband
networks to provide all of the services
there are certainly a number of key
areas of the European Commission and the
eib to collaborate on infrastructure
investment like broadband are clearly on
the top of the list and that this is
also because Europe is lagging to a
large degree compared to address areas
in terms of infrastructure investments
there's a huge need for Europe to
basically build up a 21st century type
of broadband infrastructure I'm
convinced that fiber particular FTTH is
a disruptive technology and it is the
technology which can totally change what
we can do with communications
infrastructure at the same time it is
not more expensive than the traditional
copper technology if the government
invests in telecoms it should do it in
basic infrastructure which nowadays is
Phi bar the open access is the best
solutions for everybody first of all the
carriers and the service providers they
can use the network so there is a higher
take up you can achieve more customers
on the same network if you are opening
to others service providers and the
second of all the end customers they got
the choice so they've got the freedom
they can watch wait what they want they
can use the internet providers what they
want
definitely the open access is the future
of ftth projects large is focusing on
partnership with communities because we
do believe that the neutrality and the
open access network model is the key
driver to boost competition neutrality
is a value that communities are all
ready for all services they provide to
citizens when you sync all bass or
public transports you can see called
infrastructure especially in rural areas
where we do for use in France there are
a few topics which really drive the M&A
market in telecoms and very important
topics are consolidation convergence
fixed mobile convergence in particular
there is also a strategic element so
corporates which are refocusing which
are moving to different directed regions
which are looking for other growth areas
they also tend to sell and this also
drives the M&A market in in telecoms
there is a very strong trend again
coming back to convergence so there is a
strong belief that mobile only is
perhaps not the long-term sustainable
strategy that you need to enrich it
perhaps with other services among them
fixed and fixed broadband services like
all innovation there is a certain
element of risks that goes with it and
investors typically shy away from risk
unless they see some interesting returns
now broadband investment typically
require a relatively large or long
investment period so you need have
patient shareholders or patient
investors the question is no longer if
we need fiber question only is when when
were Europe wake up and when we will see
broader rollout networks secondly I
would say speed cells so I think there
are demand drivers in the market
and thirdly infrastructure means jobs
and I think that investing in
infrastructure means investing in
broadband there will be a multitude of
positive effects on the European economy